so we talked about the github workflow
how you branch introduce changes on
commits and then merge your branch back
into master but that only works if
you're working on a project that you
have a right access to maybe you're
working on a project that you don't have
collaborator access to like if I wanted
to make changes on free code camp that's
when you would need the open source
workflow which includes forking when you
create a fork on github.com you're
creating a copy of that repository but
under your own account so you have write
access so let's say I fork free code
camps repository now I have write access
to it I can make commits directly to
that repository but they can't see them
on free code camp yet that's okay
once I create my own Fork then I'd make
commits on my fork I'd have make the
changes that I think you know free code
camp should include and then I can open
a pull request from my Fork directly to
free code camps fork the process is
overall a little bit similar to the
branching process because it includes
another copy of the code making commits
in a safe place and then introducing
them with a pull request but the main
difference is the ownership of the
separate repositories the original Fork
would be under free code camp my fork
would be under my name when we're in
using the branching process everything
is still a part of that same repository
so just to review this fork and pull
workflow is really helpful an open
source it includes creating a fork of
the repository making commits there and
then opening a pull request against the
original fork